so my name's Hiro I'm a high school
let's see I teach you ten eleven twelve
this year I'm mathematics and technology
teach other changes called from high
school before I go on I should thank
Becky and sois for the invitation
they've asked me to talk about why we
chose Ashe for our school and also to
show you a few interesting examples of
how we're using it so before I do show
you all of that there's a bit of
background our school is a public her
head selective school so we have about
500 students and you're probably those
of you who've heard of dangers will
mostly know us because of our academic
sort of achievements so I think I think
we've taught the agency about the last
15 years or thereabouts it's a highly
academically competitive environment and
you might not think that that has much
to do with the technology and how we
don't do it but it does because we've
sort of become characterized as a school
of highly experienced staff so sort of a
median age of staff it's about mmm 53 or
54
that's about the median age and that was
hired a few years ago actually when I
first arrived we've had a few
retirements since so really really
experienced teachers who know exactly
what they're doing there we're getting
great results
for many many years and so for that
reason our school is sort of with
champion the old school traditional
approach to teaching and with good
reason
they've got proven results but that also
means that we've stuck to a lot of
traditional sort of methods of
instruction and collaboration so I
arrived at the school in 2008 and as
well as teaching that's the technology I
was asked to be the intranet coordinator
and my task was so to modernize the
whole information ecosystem at the
school particularly focusing on the
Internet because that was my area that I
was interested in now on my first day as
dangerous this is what the front page of
each day looked like that but this now I
am at university I did some courses in
and I started web design on the
scientist as a part-time work but you
don't really need to have any background
in aesthetics at web design sort of cry
a little bit when you have a look at
that so this was and knows this is just
the front page but that was ever mattock
of really what the whole internet looked
like and so I think I had my work cut
out for me we thought okay we want to
really reform from the ground up
intranet and there were three particular
things principles that I had in mind but
he can change that into something far
more 21st century so the first thing
that the headline was accessibility so
this and all of the learning materials
that are sources we have it on the
intranet there were only accessible to
students on site because they resided on
on-site service so you had to log into
the school network and so on
so we thought about using the
department's reverse proxy facility to
be able to make all of this kind of
thing accessible in people from home but
there was a real question of security
which is a concern for us because you
know this resided on the same kind of
server that was connected to our entire
server cluster so we were a little
worried about if this server is
compromised or what happened to the rest
about Network secondly we wanted to not
just have accessibility but we had to
keep it right the laptops the D our
laptops which we got our first rolled
out in 2009 and when one of the schools
which has you know and above which we've
continued for once to use as soon as the
laptops arriving you probably are aware
that those are configured for internet
access not so much for integration with
our land we have a kind of we've
inherited that a rather unusual network
configuration it made it really
difficult actually for those networks
actually get onto access yes so that was
one of the first things that made us
think should we actually put everything
in the cloud which is a really scary
thought at the time so one was
accessibility to laptops 3 which is
usability so as this is an example of
the holy tremors are real
smash of front page templates organ HTML
was put out by Microsoft Word a few
brave teachers are students who hand
coded things on notepad but it was all
over the place some faculties had either
little or no material actually on the
internet because I think that in these
days people thought that you sort of
needed to know some dark arts and maybe
are the supreme temptations and
sacrifices available to actually get
something working by then and that was
just because it was so difficult to put
content up and make it accessible to
students and get me talking you know
where the stuff that I want you to get
so ease of use was a really big deal for
us that was really important priority
for whatever platform we went to so why
don't we choose apps all three of those
things
accessibility excessive being able to
get to them from the laptops we just
mainly got to be Internet and usability
it took all of those boxes for us so
number one in terms of security is
really really good I mean it's
enterprise level security on it so we
were happy with that secondly not only
could our students get to well I'll show
you what it looks like more now they
couldn't just get to a from a laptop
within the school but really in any
internet-enabled device and I was really
a positive for us over the last two
years we've seen an increase its parents
and students we're getting about on an
average month fifty-five to sixty
thousand page views and have ninety-one
percent of those are from North
Department my P addresses so we can see
that people really are using this term
outside of the school or within the
school be easier on their phones because
they can get to it just fine so security
any turn able to get to it the big was
usability so I'm not sure I am side the
environment not go into all the details
but editing Google Sites and using Doc's
is really as simple as using a word
processor which is really crucial for a
students even I don't want to talk about
digital natives and how this generation
should be able to be we spend on
we found that apart from watching videos
and chatting with Angry Birds there
actually we're not really that expert
and so having a tool which really easy
to edit content put it up allow them to
focus on the materials that were there
rather the form that it came in that was
really beneficial for us now it's
probably come worth mentioning I'm not
here to sell anything Apps is not by no
means is it a perfect solution so for
instance right at the beginning we had a
lot of really difficult issues with web
filtering and the way that the
department had its whitelist and how
they interacted with Google Sites and
dogs no no that's not Google's fault
though it is complicated by the way that
Google Apps handles attachments or the
internet and also the way it handles
sign it but that was still really big
obstacle to get over and I can talk more
about that later she's interesting also
we really love that Apps is flexible
enough and powerful enough to fit any
kind of different organization so not
just schools but there are some school
specific sort of features that we would
really die to have the things I'm
somewhere in mind for instance we look
in the calendaring system at the moment
we'd love to be able to schedule and
book ins by period rather than by the
time in the day because that's the way
that we work and we'd really love to be
able to you by term not just by month
which is the largest to kind of how many
weeks you can do it phone so we really
appreciate that so it's not a perfect
tool but at the same time as we've
invested more effort into using apps and
I'm getting as a school-wide sort of
strategy there are lots of little
benefits that we do expect so for
instance Google Docs has really become a
game changer for us for the classrooms
where it's been embraced and used on a
regular daily basis and also the latest
the ability to automate tasks on the
intranet through apps which there's a
lot of our own
design kids really love and also the
interoperability between Google Apps and
other Google services and Google s and
other Google services has been really
really beneficial so I just give you one
example create support and that other
great support coach touch football is my
sort of my favorite and we used to have
this awful system actually it was
supposed as best as we could where we
got four hundred students and they would
all get a a five slip that they'd name
then tick the box with their date of
birth and which sport they wanted and
then it got him into the paint
department and they had to sort it into
the twelve or so sports that we had and
then as a coach I would turn up on our
trials today and it'd be a weedy day and
all my my forty piece of paper fly away
and I'd be trying to manage whatever I'm
actually gonna put into his team so what
I designed with a few about year 1112
students was a system where they can
input their details and their preferred
sport through Google Docs perform really
simple output into a spreadsheet and we
got our roles automatically generated
off that spreadsheet and it just I sort
of was pitching myself on the morning
where we printed out the roles EE five
minutes used to take six to seven hours
just to get everything the right spot
make sure you hadn't put someone the
wrong pile and then to distribute
everything so that's just one little
example of how we didn't anticipate that
as a benefit but it's been really useful
now let me really quickly show you some
of the actual ways that we're using it
so this is the portal that students and
parents would get into at home or you
can access it from school obviously
every department has a tiny little
sub-site so you can see that our
resources here we have tons here and
it's sort of last count I think we're
about twenty five thousand different
files across about seven to eight
thousand different pages so a lot of
time in efforts been invested into that
I mean if I made the Publius math so if
I come down to here all of our resources
pass papers all that kind of thing it's
really well organized and we had this
consistent style it doesn't look like
different people
have come across and had completely
different designs even though actually
different people have created all these
different sections so there's faculty is
every particular extracurricular group
we have at the school I come back a
little bit has its own little section so
there's actually way more groups than
that our school we just don't have space
to put all of them so every little group
has its own section and that's sort of
our school-wide
strategy yeah some teachers like myself
have got it sort of bit of excessive
amount of resources I want to use it bit
more so we've created our own spaces for
that so for instance this is my own
class website part of the sort of rather
strange name where my students came up
with it because that's how the site
began sort of stuck from there so I use
this on a daily basis just in my lessons
I teach technology as well as maths so
when I'm doing my PT lessons if you go
to news just my normal lesson I don't I
don't give handouts a normal lesson I'll
just refer to this these are the tasks
that we'd go through it'll give them
some instructions on what to do and in
accuracy right now I know it's been an
imposing setup but I I filmed all my
lessons and this will come up later on
so that eighty students who've missed it
or if they want to revise for their
exams are coming up in four weeks this
is a really helpful resource for them
and that sort of has taken a bit about
life on its own so I'll go if you go
mm-hmm I know this is not Google Apps
but just this shows how well this can
integrate and again my students come up
with all the names because I don't shut
herself coordinated and yeah you can
don't judge me anyway I then there found
really useful not as a replacement but
maybe way as a replacement we're not
into using technology for its own sake
but this is a really helpful support for
what we're doing in the classroom and I
wake up to the place because it will
stop with anything playing my face in
one of these bad enough I won just last
thing to show you which I we really love
about what I was saying the flexibility
of a trillionth when I arrived we had a
sorry the same place we had
outside company who did our website for
our public website and they were
charging us four or five thousand
dollars a year I think basically a host
about twenty different static pages and
a few photos and I thought we can do
this better ourselves so this is sitting
on Google Sites right now we just
desired our public website using banner
and you know there's this flexibility of
design here so you can actually it's a
bit different and at the same way we
have our own students they have a a
group a union if I can spell properly
where they're kids it's your favorite
kind of thing and so we built that site
also off to Google Sites and it's really
simple to use and putting content on
there is about as easy as it gets really
and it's all still secure this links
there but you have to sign it if you
want download anything and that's how
we've been using Google Apps is just so
scratching the surface so you can
clusion we found apps to be a really
powerful and flexible sort of component
I guess about technology infrastructure
and I think it's been a really helpful
and useful part about strategy to
improve learning and communication and
organization throughout the school so
thank you